Luke from Michigan.
Tell me what is on your mind today.
I would love to hear from you.
Speaker 2: It is.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Was that a chinchilla in the background?
What was that?
Speaker 2: Oh, no, that's my desk chair.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's your chair.
Oh, my God.
I thought it was an animal.
Speaker 2: Now.
I'm a I'm a long time caller.
Not a long time time listener.
First time caller.
Beautiful.
I didn't really have a question.
Oh, to be fair, I was just kind of like listening
in.
Speaker 1: Well, can I ask you a question?
Speaker 2: Go for it.
Speaker 1: How did you first stumble across
my content?
Speaker 2: Um.
I want to say you were.
I saw some videos on YouTube and then also
I watched your livestreams of like the Trump
rallies.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So most recently, YouTube was the platform
where you came across the content.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah, that's correct.
Speaker 1: And let me ask you this.
This is just like kind of a focus group.
Once you found the content on YouTube, did
you consume content anywhere else?
Like, did you then say, Oh, I might follow
and watch your tik tok videos?
Or are you just within the YouTube universe
basically?
Speaker 2: YouTube at first, but then I found
your discord and twitch.
So I followed you and subscribed on there
as well.
Speaker 1: Interesting.
All right.
Very good.
Well, anything I can do to improve the show,
sir?
Speaker 2: No.
I really enjoy it.
Beautiful.
Speaker 1: Well, good to hear from you.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: You, too.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
Luke from Michigan, very, very important.
There is a there is an option to request to
speak also.
But I'm just kind of going around and calling
different people so we can we can figure out
how that all is going to work.
Let's go to where we going here.
Let's go to Jessica from Indiana.
Jessica from Indianapolis, welcome to the
program.
Speaker 3: Hi, thanks.
I've been like everyone else.
I've been a long time listener.
But first time.
Speaker 1: Caller.
Pleasure to have you.
Speaker 3: Two questions, if that is okay.
Sure.
So currently I'm introducing Indiana local
legislation.
As you might be aware of, Indiana is very
much a red state, and I'm currently trying
to introduce legislation to add queer people
a hate crime, protect some laws.
Currently, this is being drafted by a family
friend of mine and State Representative Renee
Pack.
Okay.
I believe to my understanding this, it is
being drafted.
It has not been introduced.
Should I be preparing some sort of like speech
to talk to the Indiana House when the bill
has been introduced?
Speaker 1: I have absolutely no idea.
Unfortunately, Jessica, I don't know the specifics
of the process there.
I just wouldn't be able to advise you on that.
If there's a possibility that you will be
speaking, it would be your call whether you
prepare a speech.
Speaker 3: That's fair enough.
Second question, you don't really have that
one.
Let me see if I can try to find it.
Okay.
Never mind.
I cannot find it.
Why do you.
Do you think it's a coincidence that it always
ends up being the people that try to get queer
books and stuff of that nature banned from
schools that end up being having predatory
issues?
Speaker 1: Well, it's not always the case.
It's not always the case.
But there is certainly a history of that where
some of the most fervent homophobes end up
being gay, for example.
But I don't know that I have any broader you
know, I'm not sure I have anything else to
say about it.
But we've covered a number of cases in which
it has happened, certainly.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Awesome.
That's all I really had.
Speaker 1: All right.
Great to hear from you, Jessica from Indianapolis.
Great to talk to you.
Just so everybody knows, there's people trying
to call me directly on discord.